[Music]
here on this video we will showcase the
15 biggest wolves and canines from
movies and shows and we are including a
couple of big dogs and werewolves as
well anyway we won't spend any time on
the intro so let's just get to it
at number 15 we have the hot dogs seen
in the 2003 movie hulk also known as
gammadogs they were three genetically
mutated hounds that david banner the
father of bruce banner made with gamma
radiation and bruce's dna their names
were smoky sammy and lily and they were
super durable ferocious and powerful
when they transformed they were each
around 1.2 to 1.5 meters or 45 feet tall
but were killed in the movie by the hulk
himself
at 14 we have the frostwolves seen in
the 2016 movie warcraft and coming from
the planet draenor frost wolves are
giant alien cannons that are used as
mounts by barbaric humanoids called orcs
not only are the frostbolts ferocious
they are clever enough to know when to
attack and when to retreat
they are around five feet tall
at 13 we have lobjaw this big job is the
inhumans companion as well as the family
job of
the royal family of the show the
inhumans as well as their teleporter
compared to other members of his species
he has a cognitive and intellectual
equivalent of a more sentient race he
appears as a big bulldog and seems to be
five and a half feet tall or more than
1.5 meters
at number 12 we have the die wolf a game
of thrones dire wolf is a close relative
of the gray wolf but larger and stronger
and smarter it is also the sigil of
house stock
they can grow larger than ponies and
twice the size of a large hounds jon
snow's direwolf ghost in the end of the
series was seen to look a man straight
face to face so he would have been
around 6 feet tall or 1.8 meters
11 walks seen in lots of the rings and
the hobbit they were a breed of wolves
who lived in the misty mountains they
are described as being giant intelligent
and malevolent wolves who obey and
follow sauron's will and are states of
goblins and orcs while most of them are
around 5-6 feet in height the matriarch
which was ridden by as outlet defiler
was around 2 meters or 6.5 feet in
height
at number 10 we have the shape shifters
from the goofy twilight movies often
mistaken as werewolves but really they
aren't they are descended from ancient
spirit warriors of the queen tribe of
north america they usually are normal
humans but for the fact that they can
turn into these beasts that look like
giant wolves and each of them have a
specific coat of fur these shape
shifters are around six to seven feet
tall
number nine lichens
these are shape-shifting monsters from
the underworld movies lichens are a
breed of werewolves created in the 13th
century and are descended from the
immortal william corvinus's bloodline
they are the enemies of the vampires and
are terrifying to look at in a good way
of course most of them are around six to
seven feet tall while the original
william was more than seven feet or 2.1
meters in height
at number 8 we have the death jackals
from the newest mcu series we have these
creepy egyptian death jackals which are
summoned by arthur harrow the antagonist
of the show using the scepter of a
goddess called ahmed they are invisible
to everyone except the god conscious
avatar called moon knight they appear to
look like anubis but are just foot
soldiers that serve the goddess of
vengeance called ahmed they are around 7
to 8 feet or two point one to two point
four meters tall
number seven gabriel also known as van
helsing from the 2004 action film of the
same name van helsing was once an angel
of god named gabriel and was his left
hand in heaven at some point of time
gabriel descended to earth and took on
living flesh becoming human he is around
2000 years old and has incredible
fighting prowess when he was bitten by a
werewolf he gained new abilities which
included changing into a 2.1 to 2.4
meters or a seven to eight feet tall
werewolf
number six bernie causer the chimera
these are strange creatures the chimera
from the im number four franchise one of
them named bernie kosar is a chimera
that travels with a character called
number four to planet earth he normally
appears in the form of a small beagle a
dog but can change into a large
monstrous dog that is around seven to
eight feet tall and fought and kill
another chimera called
at number five we have clifford the big
red dog on the fifth spot we have a
cutie a good boy
seen in the movie of the same name from
last year 2021
clifford was a small red puppy that was
adopted from an animal shelter but this
pop will grow based on how much love it
gets from its owners and after getting
him back home the pup grew overnight
into a nine feet tall red dog so much
love
number 4 cerebrus this three-headed dog
from the harry potter franchise was a
very rare magical creature and was one
of the obstacles to the philosopher's
stone it had three heads which were
conjoined at the neck it was extremely
deadly but
had a weakness to music falling asleep
to the sound of it cerebrus was around 3
meters or 10 feet tall
at number 3 we have fenris fenris the
giant asgardian wolf who served heller
during the times of the expansion of
asgard around the nine realms was one of
the most powerful and fearsome beings in
the nine realms able to fight the heart
to a stalemate and its bite was strong
enough to even pierce the thick skin of
the hulk and made him bleed green blood
fenris was around 15 feet or 4.6 meters
tall
number 2 ralph on the second spot we
have ralph from the movie rampage ralph
is a colossal wolf with gray fur over
almost all of his body and white fur on
his face
as part of his mutation ralph has
developed porcupine-like quilts on his
back as well as a fleshy membrane
located between his full and hind limbs
that allow him to glide through the air
ralph is 13 to 14 meters or around 45
feet tall number one wolf gas we end
with a kaiju from the ultraman movies
they are alien creatures and one of them
landed on earth although their sizes are
normally around just 2 meters or 6.5
feet tall they could alter their size by
consuming gas and can grow up to heights
of around 47 meters or 154 feet tall
they are as of now the biggest wolf
slash dog canine monsters seen in movies
and shows